actually let's jump into the hunter by
and stuff because uh
so i don't know if you've been following
up to date on all of this because we're
getting a slow release of
hunter biden information joe biden
information but the story is this
computer repair guy
gets a laptop yep and after a couple
months
dude never shows back up the laptop had
beau biden foundation stick around or
something
he opens it up because now it's le it's
legally his property it's been abandoned
and he finds a bunch of emails
apparently he can't he he copied the
hard drive and then gave it to the fbi
but then heard nothing
back and so then he started getting
worried thinking he was gonna get killed
and stuff like that so then he gave it
to rudy giuliani's lawyer like
i don't know i would give it to you so
now there's serious questions about what
did the fbi know
because apparently they received this in
december of 2019 when the impeachment
inquiries were going on
which led into the impeachment hearing
and this was all based on donald trump's
phone call with
uh you know the i think it was the
president or prime minister of ukraine
or something yeah i think so
well it was ukraine but it was a perfect
phone call the perfect phone call
indeed so he said you know people are
are talking about this video there's a
video a viral video where joe biden was
was
laughing about how he ousted this
prosecutor he's like son of a bee gets
fired ha ha billion dollars everyone
laughs
everyone laughs so trump has his phone
call probably saw some viral video on
the internet
didn't know much about it and passively
was like yeah i just i don't know if you
know anything about this thing with with
biden i saw
and that was really kind of but they
launched this big impeachment thing over
it
which failed the fbi had this had this
hard drive they had these emails
in these emails we've now learned so far
in only i think three or four days
that one of one of the executives for
this company that trump was
asking questions about thanked hunter
biden for introducing him giving giving
him the opportun opportunity to meet his
dad and spend time with him
whether whatever that means you
interpret the media's trying to claim it
didn't mean he actually met him that's
just kind of weird
i think spend time with him is pretty i
know i know
so but maybe it meant hunter biden and
not joe but i don't i'm not buying it
it's just colloquially so anyway look
we now have tucker carlson last night
did a segment where he said
one about one month before joe biden
went
and got this prosecutor fired there were
communications
from this company about needing to get
u.s officials to
intervene on their behalf and then it
was only like a few days before
i guess this pr company was on a was on
a phone call with the white house or
something a conference call
and then all of a sudden joe biden flies
out there fire this guy or you don't get
the money yep
guy gets fired the guy who got fired
victor shokun said he signed a sworn
affidavit
that he was going to investigate the
executives of barisma and the founder of
brismo for corruption and various things
but then joe biden got him fired so if
that information if those emails
were in the possession of the fbi at a
time when trump was being accused of
trying to
smear joe biden what was the fbi doing
you know uh i mean i i i can't i can't
uh
i can't even guess you know um but i
mean
i do think that i do think that the
so people say the deep state and i think
that when you use a term like
deep state it's such a charged term
that it's unhelpful but there is an
entrenched bureaucracy yeah of
people that work for the government
that are unelected that have no desire
to get fired
they don't want to see their job go away
they're regular people
doing what to them is fairly mundane
work
but they don't want their you know like
i said i would get rid of
you know get rid of the atf people that
work at the atf they don't want to get
rid of the atf
my mom used to work for the u.s fish and
wildlife in massachusetts
and i told her and her friends right in
front of me i'm just like
i would get rid of this whole building
y'all are fired
and they were they were they were
appalled and my mom was like
my mom was just like whatever you know
because she knows my opinion
and but they were appalled that i would
say that and i understand because you
know
if you've got a job and and you've got
your livelihood tied up with
with the government you know it it makes
sense but at the same time
you know these these
people that work for the government have
their own interests
and so to think that they wouldn't try
to
preserve their own jobs and preserve
their their
their power or whatever i think that's
that's just that's a little foolish and
to just say oh
yeah you know oh it's deep state and so
it's all just crazy
conspiracy theory no it's not it's it's
realistic to say people that have jobs
and families and pensions and all the
things that go along with the job
they want to keep those things that
makes perfect sense for sure
but there's ideology in there sure yeah
like i think i think
if if these people at the fbi like
struck lisa page yeah
the russian gay people they hated trump
yeah and and
you're right i agree with you about
ideology and i think that
donald trump is is you know just
throwing rubbing salt in the wound and
i honestly i think that i think if
donald if if
barack obama didn't make fun of donald
trump at that
at that dinner he probably wouldn't he
probably wouldn't have run
if if barack obama didn't get on late
night tv
and clown on donald trump donald trump
probably wouldn't have won so you want
to complain about something
complain about barack obama doing the
mic drop that's why you got donald trump
because you clowned him and made a fool
of him yeah yeah exactly
i mean uh a lot of people have said
trump wants to be loved so he's looking
for compromise to get the you know the
most amount of love possible
and that's uh i hear this a lot of
people talk about the bump stock ban
that he had these these these gun
control advocates
and they were being nice to him so he
was absolutely like thank you oh yeah
we'll definitely
like you be nice to the guy and the guy
he wants to
he wants you to love him yeah i agree
totally yeah
so so we we end up with we have an fbi
that has some agents now now one of
their lawyers actually got charged
so you you heard about this right didn't
they take out a bunch of insurance
policies too
yes i heard about that yes fbi agents
were taking out liability insurance
because they knew
if anyone found out about what they were
doing to trump they were gonna get in
trouble
yeah that's that's nuts that's correct
that's crazy
the fact that they took out the
insurance policies and and there
isn't a ton of journalists trying to
snoop around and come up with
information about why they were what
were you thinking and and et cetera et
cetera
is is proof that the
the media doesn't have very much
interest in actually
upsetting the apple cart you know it's
not enough
for them to not be journalists they must
actively be anti-journalists
that's how it works because that's the
truth that's that's how i see it because
when when the proud boys got name
dropped by joe biden yeah what did all
these journalists tweet out
yeah don't interview the proud boys
don't talk about them all of that
it was like one person tweeted and then
someone would quote it and create this
chain of all the journalists being like
we vow
not to actually explore who these people
are which is insane
because a presidential candidate name
dropped them and one of them said stand
back and stand by
incredible kind of important to figure
out who he's telling to stand by you
would think so but
as long as the as long as the
the general tone that your normies
are going to have about or the attitude
that normies have generally about the
proud boys
is that they're the bad guys they don't
want to touch it they don't want anyone
to dive in and find out that the proud
boys have
you know black members and and you know
the cuban
american uh they don't want people to
know yeah they don't want people to know
yeah it started as like a ridiculous
joke based on the latin
song yeah name the cereals yeah the
naming the cereal things was based off
of when someone farts
they can punch you until you name five
cereals of course oh that's what it was
then it turned into getting that's how
you got in okay so
so did you ever play the game doorknobs
no when so we used to do this in chicago
if someone farted yep safety okay
so you you know the farts coming on you
you you fart with safety
but if you don't someone yells doorknobs
they start punching you until you touch
a doorknob
that's the that's a chicago version and
forget for gavin it was
name five breakfast cereals and they'd
stop punching you
and so it was clearly all a really dumb
joke yeah that got taken way too far
but still you know i always say like if
these guys were if when they announced
doing a rally
if nobody shows up you know what happens
nothing happens they they wander around
they sing
they sing the national anthem they get
drunk and they go home yeah they go to a
bar and they drink that's it nothing
happens
they're just it's just like frat bros
going around and chest bumping each
other and stuff
antifa shows up however so that you know
we i'm not going to rehash all that
stuff but the point is
the news organizations didn't want
anyone to realize they're not a white
supremacist group
like you you can criticize them for a
lot of things we had you know enrique in
the show and we and we we
you know we had a bit of back and forth
on some issues but uh right now
you know the media had not at that time
i should say the media media had an
opportunity
because donald trump said stand back
stand by they wanted it to be white
supremacy
yeah but if they actually interviewed
enrique tario who's not white
then that would have been bad because it
would have broken the narrative
ruined it so then you know what what did
we see with that that town hall last
night with savannah guthrie
she again asks trump will you denounce
white supremacy
and trump's like ah you know what they
told me backstage you were going to ask
me this
he asked every single time and she was
like aren't you a little you're a little
hesitant he's like no i denounced white
supremacy
yeah i you i've i've heard donald trump
say that i denounced white supremacy
more times than i've heard any other
human being
say i dance white springs i have
literally out of all the people that
i've ever
interacted with in my entire 45 years
i've heard donald trump say i denounced
white supremacy more than anyone and
he's still
asked to announce whitespace so here's
the bigger picture in all this because
we
we jump from like the bidens and out to
the media it's the entirety of the
establishment it is
big tech twitter facebook this is
something ian you probably know a bit
about especially when it comes to like
because you you moderated for mines
so you've got twitter and facebook story
comes out they nuked the story
completely the crazy thing was before
anything happened
facebook this guy andy stone who worked
for the democrat said we're reducing its
visibility or whatever or to reach or
something
why are these individuals censoring a
story that made joe biden look bad
then and their excuses kept changing for
facebook it was oh it's unverified
for twitter they said because they
didn't publish where the origins were
it's possibly hacked
so they shut it down then it was oh no
they revealed private information
now they're like okay it's actually fine
now it was ridiculous it was all
ridiculous
just garbage to to try to
uh you know cover up the story or or
limit it's its reach
and the thing that's the thing that
surprises me the most is
is people just kind of bought that
and we're like yeah okay we're not we
don't you know okay this is this this is
something like
that's the story like the biden stuff
isn't as big of a story
as you know the the cover-up and now
you've got the
aren't they going to be going doesn't
jack have to go to capitol hill so far
it's an invite i think it's an invite
yeah and they always ignore this stuff
that's why i'm like so so i think josh
hawley tries
you know he really tries to get to the
bottom of the censorship and the
manipulation and stuff
but he doesn't have the power we're not
a country of despots as much as the left
wants to claim trump and republicans are
fascists they can't do much
ridiculous yeah so these companies keep
getting away with it yeah just so i saw
i made a post about this i'm like i when
when when twitter blocked the government
the house website house.gov yeah that
was wow that was i was like welcome to
black mirror baby that's it i'm not even
i'm not even gonna be serious about this
anymore when the story first came out i
was like this is it
you know or when they censored the new
york post i'm like they are actively now
cheating to help the democrats win it's
there's no question because when trump's
taxes tax information was released by
the new york times
trump denied it yeah that means the
information was not verified in fact it
was refuted
and no one cared when the leaked melania
tapes came out
no one cared this information oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa we gotta
shut it down guys shut down and what do
i hear from my lefty friends
but the story is not verified yeah when
have you ever asked me to verify any of
these stories
never i can put out a story where it's
like donald trump smacked a kid in the
face and you're gonna be like wow
i believe it that orange man is so bad
can you believe he smacked a kid
i totally can what what is it about this
like
i'm not even sure i'm not even convinced
it's it's an actual
establishment of people as much as it is
some kind of
weird mind frame where you have a bunch
of people that can only
point in a certain direction so
basically i'll put this way
if the news comes out saying trump is
bad it's immediately accepted except
that it's true
demi lovato is like i'm going to
criticize the president even if it hurts
my
my career come on yeah like
then taylor swift come up with a song or
something i love taylor swift i love her
to death and
as much as as much as uh i disagree with
her on politics
i will still consume whatever taylor
swift puts out
didn't you see that one with no shame no
questions no shame you know
what's that song where it's like um
what's that what's it called
you're you're you're talking too loud
you better calm down you need to calm
down you come down yeah yeah it was like
the music video she put out was a
caricature of
you know of like hillbilly republicans
in the
in the early 90s or something moran sign
and like being anti-lgbt
or whatever and i'm like trump was was
pro-gay marriage before he became
president
like what year are you looking from they
got some old guy who's producing the
music video
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you